but back to eric because
he had a wonderful conversation in that
conversation
he played the big brother role and he
was very happy about it
he was self-congratulatory about it i
mean
can you talk to the ways in which eric
made you a better man
throughout your life yeah hell yeah
i mean for one thing you know eric and i
are interestingly similar in some ways
and radically different in some other
ways and it you know it's often a
matter of fascination to people who know
us both because almost always people
meet one of us first and they sort of
get used to that thing and then they
meet the other and it throws the model
into chaos
but you know i had a great advantage
which is i came second
right so although it was kind of a pain
in the ass to be born into a world that
had eric in it because he's a force of
nature
right it was also terrifically useful
because
a he was a very awesome older brother
who you know made interesting mistakes
learned from them and conveyed the
wisdom of what he had discovered
and that was uh you know i don't know
who else
ends up so lucky is to have that kind of
person blazing the trail
it also probably you know my my
hypothesis for what birth order effects
are
is that they're actually adaptive right
that the reason that a second born is
different than a firstborn
is that they're not born into a world
with the same niches in it right
and so the thing about eric is he's been
completely dominant
in the realm of fundamental
thinking right like what he's fascinated
by is the fundamental of fundamentals
and he's excellent at it which meant
that i was born into a world where
somebody was becoming excellent in that
and for me
to be anywhere near the fundamental of
fundamentals was going to be pointless
right i was going to be playing second
fiddle forever and i think that that
actually drove me to the other end
of the continuum between fundamental and
emergent and so i became fascinated with
biology and have been since i was
three years old right i think eric drove
that
and i have to thank him for it because
you know i mean
i never thought of so eric
drives towards the fundamental and you
drive towards the emergent
the physics and the biology right
opposite ends of the continuum and
as eric would be quick to point out if
he was sitting here
i treat the emergent layer i seek the
fundamentals in it which is sort of an
echo of
eric's style of thinking but applied to
the very far
complexity he's uh overpoweringly
argues for the importance of physics the
fundamental
of the fundamental
he's not here to defend himself is there
an argument to be made
against that or biology the emergent
the study of the thing that emerged when
the fundamental
acts at the universal at the cosmic
scale and builds
the beautiful thing that is us is much
more important
like uh psychology biology
the systems that we're actually
interacting with in this
human world are much more important to
understand than
um low-level uh theories
of uh quantum mechanics and general
relativity
now i can't say that one is more
important i think there's probably a
different
time scale i think understanding the
emergent layer
is more often useful but the
bang for the buck at the far fundamental
layer
may be much greater so for example the
fourth frontier
i'm pretty sure it's going to have to be
fusion powered
i don't think anything else will do it
but once you had fusion power
assuming we didn't just dump fusion
power on the market the way we would be
likely to if it was invented
usefully tomorrow but if we had fusion
power
and we had a little bit more wisdom than
we have you could do an awful lot and
that's not going to come
from people like me who you know
look at dynamics can i can i argue
against that
please i think
the way to uh unlock fusion power
is through artificial intelligence is so
i think most of the breakthrough ideas
in the futures of science will be
developed by ai systems
and i think in order to build
intelligent ai systems
you have to be a scholar of the
fundamental of the
emergent of biology
of the neuroscience of the way the brain
works of intelligence of consciousness
and those things at least directly don't
have anything to do with physics
well you're making me a little bit sad
because my
addiction to the aha moment thing is
incompatible with
you know uh outsourcing that job like
the outsourcing i don't want to
outsource that thing to the moment
um you know and actually i've seen this
happen before because some of the people
who
uh trained heather and me were
phylogenetic systematists
uh arnold kluge in particular
and the problem with systematics is that
to do it right
when your technology is primitive you
have to be
deeply embedded in the philosophical and
the logical
right your method has to be based in
the highest level of rigor once you can
sequence genes
genes can spit so much data at you that
you can overwhelm
high quality work with just lots and
lots and lots of automated work
and so in any in some sense there's like
a generation of phylogenetic
systematists
who are the last of the greats because
what's replacing them is sequencers
um so anyway i maybe you're right about
the ai
and i guess i don't know what you said i
i like figuring stuff out is there
something that you disagree with eric on
they've been trying to convince them
you've failed so far
but uh you will eventually succeed
you know that is a very long list eric
and i have
have uh tensions over certain things
that recur
all the time and i'm trying to think
what would be
you know the idea in the space of
science in the space of philosophy
politics family
love robots
well all right let me i'm just going to
use your
podcast to uh make a bit of a cryptic
war and just say there are
many places in which i believe that i
have
butted heads with eric over the course
of decades and i have seen him move
in my direction substantially over
you've been winning
he might he wouldn't battle here there
but you've been winning the war i would
not say that
it's quite possible he could say the
same thing about me and in fact i know
that it's true there are places where
he's absolutely convinced me but
in any case i do believe it's at least
you know it may not be a totally even
fight but
it's more even than some will imagine um
but yeah we
have um you know there are things i say
that drive him
nuts right like when something
you know like you heard me talk about
the um
what was it it was the autopilot
that seems to be putting a great many
humans in
needless medical jeopardy over the covet
19 pandemic
and my feeling is we can say this
almost for sure anytime you have the
appearance of some
captured gigantic entity that is
censoring you on youtube and you know
handing down dictates from the who and
all of that it is sure that there will
be
a certain amount of collusion right
there's going to be some embarrassing
emails
in some places that are going to reveal
some shocking connections and then
there's going to be an
awful lot of emergence that didn't
involve collusion right in which people
were doing their little part of a job
and something was emerging and you never
know what the admixture is
how much are we looking at actual
collusion and how much are we looking at
an emergent process but you should
always walk in
with the sense that it's going to be a
ratio and the question is what is the
ratio in this case
i think this drives eric nuts um because
he is very focused on the people i think
he's focused on the people who have a
choice
and make the wrong one and anyway
he makes a question of the ratio is a
distraction to that
i think i think he takes it almost as an
offense
because it grants cover
to people who are harming others
and i think i think it defends him
morally and if i had to say i would say
it alters his judgment on the matter
but anyway certainly useful just leave
open
the two possibilities and say it's a
ratio but we don't know which one
brother is a brother do you love the guy
hell yeah hell yeah and you know i'd
love him if he's just my brother but
he's also awesome
so i love him and i love him for who he
is
you